he would see something
it takes an army of animators to bring
us our favorite movies so it's no
surprise that some mistakes happen and
we forgive the animators because it
makes it more fun for us the audience to
comb through and find them we're
sleuthing out the mistakes in disney's
latest animated movies starting off with
the charming encanto
number one if we remember correctly
dolores isn't the shapeshifter during
the song we don't talk about bruno you
may recall this little scene of the
family dancing around mirabelle but did
you notice how the woman holding the
dead fish dances off screen and suddenly
dolores is in her place
we definitely think this one was a
mistake because the fish woman is the
only outsider in this scene and then
just disappears midway through if it by
chance wasn't a mistake it's at the very
least quite an odd artistic choice don't
you think
we say nothing number two the totally
normal box of fun has more magical
powers than anybody's letting on
the not-so-special special that
mirabelle has handed has the maracas
facing her which would make for a super
awkward way to hold a basket full of
thingamabobs but in the next shot the
basket appears flipped around now the
maracas are facing away from her
delivery
i gave you the special number three
luisa's the strong one not the
teleporting one the position of louisa
changes in this scene she's obviously
behind camilo in one shot and in the
next is very much in front hey maybe
she's actually that shape-shifting kid
in disguise wait no camilo is the
shape-shifting kid sorry it's hard to
keep them all straight maybe we need to
re-listen to that song
number four babies are escape artists in
raya and the last dragon we don't
remember noi having the power of super
speed but somehow she managed to get
from on top of tuk tuk to down beside
tong for when he picks her up and we
seriously doubt she made a sudden
decision to jump we'll forgive the
animators it's definitely a tender
moment for noi and tong and we would
rather have it than not have it we bet
the animators noticed it and chose not
to change it it probably would have been
a huge pain to reanimate noi on the
ground the entire scene leading up to
the moment
noi
it's her name number five there's
nothing sadder than your ice cream
suddenly disappearing on you unless of
course you'd already dropped it on the
ground then who cares maybe a seagull
snuck away with it but there's no
remnants of it ever existing so we're
guessing not
maybe i said it wrong
number six do the fish people turn into
fish on the insides when they drink
water we're just wondering this
animation concern is more a question of
continuity than an animating mistake per
se how do the characters immediately
turn human upon jumping out of the water
while still wet and in other shots the
boys struggle to turn back to being
human and it takes forever for them to
dry off do we really care no not at all
because the shots of luca and alberto
jumping out of the water are fantastic
and the moments of almost being caught
are obviously very important for the
stakes of the movie and for our laughs
number seven maybe the canvases are
imbued with the same magic as maui's
tattoos the canvas beside the maui
canvas is a three-headed monster in one
shot but once the chief comes in and is
tackled by children it completely
changes the next time we see it and now
depicts an island we don't think our
theory behind these canvases is
completely impossible what do you think
simple mistake there are no monsters
number eight perhaps it's tongue works
like window blinders those things are a
pain the water monster has moana almost
entirely in his mouth in one shot and
the next she's still completely out of
it you really can't blame this one on
the angle it's almost like the magic of
cinema is what saved her you're no one
pharaoh
no one
[Music]
number nine if only our hair could be
this cooperative for selfies grandma
tala's hair was over her right shoulder
in one shot and the very next draped
across her back
number 10 online kanto has these thank
you at the end of the movie when miguel
finally comes back to the land of the
living ernesto's tomb is wide open
allowing him to leave but the doors were
closed and locked earlier in the movie
and the guitar is still left in the
exact same position so nobody has been
inside since
what are you doing with that
number 11. if they'd vanished for more
than just a shot that would really help
our heroes along the security guards
disappear in a shot with mama emelda and
ernesto de la cruz did you catch that
although this doesn't feel so much like
a continuity error but more the creators
just wanting to set up a very
distinctive and beautiful shot with the
bright colors framing our characters if
the security guards were in the
background of the shot we feel like it
would just take away from the final
product what do you think
number 12. reindeers are stealthier than
people there's actually a bunch of
continuity errors in frozen two we
imagine it comes with the territory of
sequels here's the first of several sven
in the matter of a couple seconds
managed to completely sneak out of frame
while the gang was chatting is nobody
watching the reindeer do we really trust
him to be left to his own devices
that was magic
did you see that of course i saw it
number 13. how far back did they really
get bounced it didn't seem like more
than a couple of feet okay kristoff just
attempted to enter the spooky mist and
got nowhere so they're literally right
there at the wall but when elsa touches
the mist and it disperses we get this
big wide shot of the mist anna and elsa
and suddenly kristoff is out of frame
and has to walk like 20 feet to catch up
with them how does that make sense we do
this together okay
number 14 which side of the sword is
more dangerous anna is gripping the
icicle sword as it faces towards her
head which seems just slightly more
dangerous than running with scissors
perhaps the animator who did the next
shot realized this and didn't want her
to be impaled and so reversed the sword
or maybe the logic they used to justify
it is that in the matter of seconds the
icicles melted and then refroze on the
other side would you buy that with us
the movie is playing with the elements
so it's always a possibility
number 15 to the left to the left anna
appears on the wrong side of elsa in
this shot where the camera sneaks up
from behind maybe anna was just playing
a game where she tapped on elsa's
shoulder and then snuck around her we
know it you know it not a mistake just a
prank right okay fine the camera's
flipped the characters are flipped it's
got to be hard to do some mental math
for who goes where we still hold our
fingers up to figure out which way is
left so who are we to judge
uh what's happening that's it number 16.
it would be weird if the dad was legs in
just like an eighth of his stomach right
it's debatable if this is really a
mistake or not but it is strange we get
a pretty good idea of what the dad's
shirt looks like as he's brought back to
life but once he stumbles into the
laundry he comes back out just with
glowing pants maybe it was some sort of
snapback motion either way we didn't see
it so we're calling it a mistake
hi
dad number 17 markers like legos appear
out of nowhere in this shot it isn't
here in the next it is remember those
crayola pipsqueak markers with the fun
names like small potatoes we bet it was
that kind they were the funnest and we
bet this one is called the little boy
blue think about it it makes total sense
we've got the little boy blue elf and
the man on the moon distant father
father who's passed away who's smart we
are
number 18 clean up on aisle 2
disappearing soda isn't exactly as sad
as disappearing ice cream but still sad
nonetheless it's been dropped just
outside the doorway in this shot but
once the bikes are knocked over you can
clearly see to the side that the soda is
gone perhaps another magical creature
handled the mess swiftly but we
seriously doubt it
this one's lucky i know it number 19 if
not the devil maybe barley's got some
spider-man powers that's that's a joke
because tom holland voices ian okay
um
sure sorry bad joke should have made a
star-lord one instead barley's on top of
the passenger seat and then suddenly is
on ian's shoulder brother no brother
brother no brother the elf on his
shoulder appears as fast as the devils
and angels perhaps if no spidey powers
were being used there was a poof we just
didn't get to see
number 20 maybe joe's real purpose is to
be a magician
the things in joe gardner's hands switch
around from one shot to the next
originally the pizza crust is on the
right in one shot and in the next the
bagel and spool of thread suddenly made
their way to the right wow
that's uh great
we're quick to assume all of these
moments are mistakes that the animators
completely missed
but the truth is animators only have so
much time to finish a shot and sometimes
perhaps continuity must be sacrificed in
order to give us more easter eggs or
other special moments
like that moment where maui kicks a rock
that would have been a character choice
made by that animator who probably
didn't do the shot before it like 7
seconds of animation is something like
168 frames imagine painting that many
paintings
of course we didn't even cover half of
the animation mistakes so help us out
what's the wildest continuity error
you've ever come across in a disney
movie let us know in the comments and
thanks for watching